bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors le réacteur
numéro un de fessenheim va être arrêté
cette nuit comment cela va se va t-il se
passer c'est un arrêt qui est programmé
donc préparé et ça ne pose aucun
problème technique pour les techniciens
de la centrale
ils ont l'habitude de faire ça ce n'est
pas un arrêt d'urgence donc tout est
prêt à mon avis pour ça si on ne verra
rien de particulier cette nuit c'est
comment on le fait régulièrement tous
les ans pratiquement sur les créateurs
là on verra bien par contre c'est ce qui
va se passer après dans les mois qui
vont venir pas dans les jours mais dans
les mois qui vont venir
et effectivement puisqu'il est question
de défaire un démantèlement de ses
démons talent de certains ces relations
duclair rapidement c'est ce que disent
les autorités en fait il faut du temps
ça prendra beaucoup de temps
alors depuis valéry giscard d'estaing
jusqu'à emmanuel macron le démantèlement
de la centrale a été une longue saga on
peut dire que c'est une bataille un peu
environnementale
concrètement quelles sont les
conséquences sur l'écologie le
démantèlement n'est n'a pas été
programmé pour l'instant c'est à dire le
programme du démantèlement il a été
déposé par edf edf a demandé
l'autorisation d'arrêter c'est la
première phase pour le premier réacteur
le deuxième ce sera au mois de juin la
deuxième chose c'est il ya un plan pour
démanteler ce plan a été déposée par edf
récemment voilà dans quel qu'est ce
qu'on va faire dans quel ordre
avec quelles techniques etc ce plan a
été pour l'instant recruté par
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire française
en estimant qu'ils n'étaient pas
conformes aux règles de radioprotection
de sécurité donc il va y avoir dans un
premier temps des négociations entre
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire et edf
pour savoir comment on va procéder au
démantèlement cette installation
nucléaire
c'est pas une opération simple
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
parce qu'il y a
de la radioactivité c'est une centrale
qui a eu des problèmes de fuite des
incidents d emmener des pollutions dans
les installations dans l'environnement
qui fait que ce sera évidemment beaucoup
plus compliqué pour compte que ce qu'on
a fait pour construire cette centrale
nucléaire est donc ça nécessitera du
temps de l'argent évidemment et puis ça
générera des déchets c'est là je dirais
pour moi la plus grosse préoccupation du
point de vue environnemental
parce que sa crainte génère de grandes
quantités de déchets beaucoup de déchets
très radioactifs pour certains est très
différent très varié très variés et pour
lesquels la grande majorité ces déchets
n'ont pas aujourd'hui de filières
d'élimination
et là il va y avoir un débat qui est
déjà un petit peu engagés qu'est ce
qu'on va faire par exemple des
ferrailles des grandes quantités de
ferraille issus du démontage et qui vont
être qu'ils sont un peu radioactive et
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
évidemment le dff aimerait que ça lui
coûte le moins cher possible et ce que
en edf envisage dans ce cas là c'est de
créer une fonderie sur le site en tout
cas c'est ce que edf a annoncé une
fonderie sur le site même de fessionnels
qui permettrait de refondre ces
ferrailles bon pourquoi pas mais c'est
pour les vendre dans le domaine public
c'est à dire que l'on puisse retrouver
sa chez chez nous chez dans notre
voiture dans notre maison et ça je pense
que la can ou à la criirad c'est ce
qu'on espère c'est que ras débat et
qu'on n'autorisera pas l'exploitant à
pratiquer cette cette élimination de ce
type de déchets parce que là ça veut
dire qu'on va retrouver la radioactivité
partout dans l'autre environ ce sera
évidemment au détriment de notre santé
donc nous les déchets radioactifs qui
vont être issu ce démantèlement est bien
nous souhaitons c'est qu'ils soient
traités comme des déchets radioactifs
c'est à dire
dans des centres adaptés à ça alors le
démantèlement et la s'étaler sur sur 20
ans démantèlement de cette ou les deux
ouais alors pour les optimistes mais
c'est une centrale qui date quand même
de 1977 est la plus vieille de france on
l'a dit elle était prévu que pour 40 ans
et pourtant elle fonctionne toujours est
ce que c'est un danger
nous on pense que effectivement c'est
une centrale qui a dépassé l'âge limite
pour lequel elle avait été conçue et
pour lequel elle avait même été
prolongée déjà et c'est vrai que plus on
fait tourner ce type d'installation qui
a eu des problèmes comme toutes les
autres et il ya des pièces qui se sont
usés et qui présentent des risques ça
c'est clair
et si on avait dû facile edf avait
obtenu l'autorisation de encore prolongé
déjà encore au delà je dirais des 45 ans
47 ans voire des ça veut dire qu'il
aurait fallu faire des travaux qui
évidemment n'ont pas été fait ici
impressionnante puisque edf savez que
c'est elle était programmée dans l'arrêt
de l'ensemble d'un don d'une partie du
parc nucléaire
donc elle n'a pas fait ses travaux ça
veut dire que pendant un certain temps
moins quelques années oui cette centrale
à fonctionner jusqu'à maintenant avec
des niveaux de sécurité qui ne sont pas
optimum en fonction de critères qui sont
définies par les autorités de sûreté
nucléaire et qui sont sans doute
peut-être insuffisant non plus merci
beaucoup roland desbordes pour être
intervenu en direct sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes président de la
commission de recherche et d'information
indépendantes sur la radioactivité merci